je prends pas de plaisir quand je le
fais je sais pas sexuellement excité
pour dessous d'ailleurs enfin vraiment
c'est ça m'a jamais fait fantasmer de
faire des films porno c'est pas du tout
mon fantasme sexuel mais pas du tout
quoi
vous vous êtes étudiante en philosophie
vous êtes marié depuis peu aussi à
quelqu'un qui est en train de je crois
de passer une thèse aussi en philosophie
et alors vous vous depuis un an vous
avez fait un film vous allez en faire un
deuxième film X comment vous arrivez à
juxtaposer donc le la pornographie et la
philosophie moi ça ne mette pour plus
tard travailler une philosophie
l'obscène et ça c'est c'est pas c'est
pas mon problème maintenant dans
l'immédiat c'est pas pour ça que je fais
du porno pour moi le faire un film porno
c'est c'est de l'expression corporelle
c'est une performance corporelle moi
j'ai fait de la danse je fais pas mal de
dents je fais de la danse classique du
Modern Jazz la danse africaine la danse
orientale et je le vis pareil je vis
mieux je dirais
maîtriser son corps c'est même pas aller
aux limites de son corps c'est maîtriser
encore il y a il y a d'autres moyens
pour le faire que de passer par le X
c'est vrai j'aurais pu j'aurais pu faire
plein d'autres choses je pourrais faire
enfin je fais je j'ai envie de monter
d'autres performances ceci dit qu'ils
soient pas seulement dans la performance
ça c'est le mot qui revient on est
performances plus au sens artistique je
fais quelque chose de mon corps je fais
quelque chose de beau avec mon corps
alors pourquoi tu porno ben parce que je
trouve ça beau c'est beau le porno moi
je trouve ça très beau quand je fais un
film voir des plans hard des gros plans
comme ça
complètement avec des sexes complètement
Imberts tout propre complètement
aseptisé moi je trouve ça très beau moi
je trouve pas ça excitant j'ai jamais
été depuis que depuis que je suis jeune
depuis que j'ai 16 ans je regarde
beaucoup de films porno j'en consomme
beaucoup et je trouve pas je trouve pas
ça excitant j'ai alors pourquoi vous les
regardez excusez-moi parce que
normalement c'est vrai que c'est fait
pour cela parce que parce que c'est vrai
que je trouve ça chouette de regarder ça
de je très jolie tout simplement on est
plus on est plus il y a 10 ou 15 ans
quand même aujourd'hui il y a des gens
qui font des belles choses faut pas
c'est bien c'est bien tourné et moi je
trouve qu'il y a un esthétisme de
l'obscène je trouve que obscène c'est
vraiment le bon terme on voit tout c'est
cru on voit tout c'est clair et moi
c'est ce côté cru aseptisé que je trouve
que je trouve intéressant c'est un peu
moi je compare souvent le cinéma porno a
du cinéma gore du cinéma Z tellement on
voit tout on ouvre tout on voit tout
alors après pour vous tellement beau que
vous avez eu envie de passer de l'autre
côté ouais j'ai eu envie de le faire moi
je suis je prends pas je prends pas de
plaisir quand je le fais je suis pas
sexuellement excité pour dessous
d'ailleurs enfin vraiment c'est ça m'a
jamais fait fantasmer de faire des films
porno c'est pas du tout mon fantasme
sexuel mais pas du tout quoi enfin vous
ne parlez jamais du mot exhibitionnisme
non mais ça existe en vous non plus
en dessous moi j'ai aucune pudeur
vraiment j'ai un problème j'ai aucune
aucune morale aucune pudeur et c'est
vrai que me montrer nu me montrer
en train de
je sais pas ça me choque pas du tout
quoi
c'est normal c'est tout à fait normal
donc c'est pas du tout par exhibitionné
j'ai même pas envie de provoquer les
gens est-ce que vous pensez l'une et
l'autre que des mentalités ont beaucoup
changé moi tout ce que je vois c'est que
Ben le marché de la pornographie est un
marché qui marche bien et qu'à partir du
moment où ça rentre dans l'économie
capitalisme ça passe mieux dans les
mœurs c'est normal tout ce qui fait
fonctionner capitalisme passe mieux dans
les mœurs des gens ont les conditionne
pour ça donc c'est normal qu'aujourd'hui
il trouve que le porno ma foi c'est pas
une chose aussi condamnable qui qui a de
nombreuses vous commencez comment c'est
vécu je m'en fiche de ce que les gens
pensent dans mon entourage plus proche
bon ben mes amis si elles étonnent pas
ils se disent que c'est une chose de
plus parmi tant d'autres de toute
manière
vous êtes considérés comme original oui
parce que c'est vrai que je fais pas mal
de choses qui qui pourrait étonner qui
maintenant étonne plus personne mais je
suis un peu originale j'ai des choix de
vie qui sont un peu spéciaux qui sont
pas les mêmes que ceux qui ont mon âge
parce que je suis jeune j'ai que 19 ans
quand même je suis partie très très tôt
de chez mes parents c'est vrai que j'ai
toujours adopté un style de vie très
différent des gens de mon âge donc je me
suis mariée très tôt et votre mari alors
qui sera bientôt professeur j'imagine
enseigner
donc ça s'est fait comment ça en
concertation avec lui à 18 ans un jour
on est allé à au salon de la vidéo haute
et bon bah ça s'est fait comme ça on m'a
proposé j'ai accepté et voilà quoi mais
c'est de façon c'est comme ça c'est
comme ça qui me connaît c'est comme ça
qui m'a choisi qui m'a aimé
ça n'a pas étonné du tout de toute
manière vous accompagner sur le tournage
où il est resté j'avais envie qui voit
que on est coupé toutes les 5 minutes
que on prend pas de plaisir que on n'est
pas traité comme de la viande que ça se
passe bien que on abuse pas on abuse pas
des actrices qu'on les laisse faire ce
qu'elles veulent que si elles veulent
pas faire quelque chose elles le font
pas en tout cas sur ce film là en tout
cas sur ce film là et sur sur tous les
films que je vais accepter de faire il y
en a que j'ai refusé érotisme ça c'est
autre chose le autisme ses pensées le
sexe moi moi je le pense
j'espère le penser plus tard par écrit
dans mes travaux de philosophie mais ça
c'est parce que je fais pour le moment
pour le moment je suis vraiment dans la
matière quoi vraiment dans la matière
qu'est-ce que vous voulez faire vous
dans les années à venir j'espère faire
au moins aussi bien que mon mari
finalement ma thèse et être maître de
conférence plus tard à la fac vous
n'avez pas peur que que justement cette
expérience dans le porno que vous voulez
visiblement poursuivre un moment donné
n'arrête vos études j'ai commencé le
porno l'année dernière j'ai fini mon
année avec mention
rien à dire c'est ça
tout à fait compatible un moment donné
vous pensez qu'il en sortira quelque
chose qu'il y aura un livre une
réflexion quelque chose à partir de
bien qu'est-ce que vous avez proposé
comme sujet de maîtrise alors comme
sujet exact je sais pas mais quelque
chose qui portera justement sur
l'obscène vous saurez de quoi vous
parlez ah je saurais de quoi je parle
c'est sûr si un jour vous devenez star
ouais
c'est possible c'est possible ouais je
vous vois mal aller jusqu'à la thèse de
philo quand même pourquoi pas
on n'est pas obligé de tourner 800 films
pour être star du porno après c'est
chacun ses choix on peut devenir star en
quelques films il y a un exemple Tanya
Russof elle a tourné deux ou trois films
je sais pas et on entend parler dans
chaque dans chaque magazine d'après
spécialiste non mais vous aimeriez que
l'on parle de vous de venir une star du
porno
donc étudiante en philo moi j'ai envie
de me faire un nom ouais j'ai envie de
vous faire un nom dans le porno parce
que j'ai envie que la personne qui
écrira des bouquins sur l'obscène la
personne qui fera de la musique la
personne qui fera d'autres performances
et qu'il est présentera à des galeries
j'ai envie que cette même personne se
soit Ovidie star du X
pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne Ina
Mireille Dumas abonnez-vous et activez
la cloche
[Musique]